- Hi everyone, my name is Heinrich,
and welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
I hope you all had a good week.
Today the weather is
super bad here in Germany,
and I was sitting alone at my desk today,
and I asked myself, what
other topic Can I bring you
that will really make a
difference in your work life.
And one of the things
that quickly came to my mind is feedback.
How to actually give good
feedback that is received well,
and actually valuable for
the person who receives this.
And my experience,
this is something that
many people struggle with.
In my career, I received
many pieces of bad feedback.
Bad feedback for me is a
feedback that makes me feel bad
after I leave the conversation,
and doesn't really help me
to improve my actual work.
This is bad feedback because
it's no value add for everybody
is just losers leaving the table.
And just to help you better
understand the difference.
I'd like to contrast two managers of mine
in the past in consulting career.
One manager, there was a
situation where I was creating
a PowerPoint document,
and he was reviewing it
as a pretty much happens every
single day in consulting.
So he was going through the pages,
and then there was one important page,
and we were sitting together,
and he was saying something
like, "Yeah, I pretty like this,
probably we can change this
"and let this be shown a bit differently,
"and let's change the text here a bit."
And then he was basically
doing it on the piece of paper,
and giving it to me, and
thank you please improve.
And that was for me, okay,
in the beginning he said,
he was fine with it, I mean,
he pretty much changed
the whole page afterwards.
But it was okay, I knew
what was happening,
and I kind of took his
points and thought myself,
how can I improve for the future, right?
This being contrasted
with another manager,
pretty much same situation,
I was working on a deck,
he was reviewing it, and
he was looking at a page,
and pretty much was saying,
"Heinrich this is complete
garbage, please do that again."
What is the impact of that on me?
Of course, I feel bad, I
feel like I created garbage,
which of course nobody wants to create.
And it also didn't really have me to know
how I can actually approve
it and make it better.
And I hope just taking
this as a starting point,
it becomes clear that how
you deliver the feedback
really makes a difference.
And it can either help
somebody, built him up
and help him to make a
better work next time.
Or it can leave somebody just hurt,
and without any clue on
how to improve the job.
If you're in the early
years of your career,
you might ask yourself,
Well, why do I actually need
to know how to give feedback anyways,
isn't just the others
who will give feedback
to me in the beginning?
And why this for sure might be true.
Usually, there are several instances
where you can use this, right?
Often pretty early on you at
some point get maybe an intern
you work with, and then you would like
to give feedback to the intern.
Or also many organizations if you actually
do a feedback session
with one of your managers,
of course in the beginning,
you get the feedback
from the manager, but
then usually there's also
an opportunity where you can get feedback
to the manager, right?
Because the manager
wants to improve as well.
Yes, this does depend on the culture
of this actually something that happens.
But in many organizations,
this is how it's done.
And before I'd like to
give you a framework
on how you can actually
structure and deliver
your feedback in a constructive way,
let me make two preliminary remarks,
which I believe are really crucial
to the whole feedback thing, right?
And the first thing is that
you need to distinguish
the person from an action or a task.
I believe that it is almost
never had fully constructive
to say, you are a bad
person, you can't do it,
you are not ready for the job, right?
Because things like that, I
wouldn't even consider feedback.
This is pretty much just
an insight that is about
to just bring that person down,
and it's not helping the person at all.
If you would like to get feedback,
never directly related to the person,
but make it about the work,
on action of the person.
Don't say you did a crappy
job, but rather say,
the document that you created,
the work that you did,
just didn't met the expectations,
or the thing that you did
in that specific meeting or
on that specific instance,
from my perspective isn't the right
for these reasons, right?
So always talk about actions or the work,
but never talk about an
attribute of the person himself,
don't criticize the character of a person,
because this is not giving feedback,
this is just being offensive.
The second general remark is
that you should always be aware
that what you're saying
is your perception,
your personal perception,
and for two reasons.
First, for yourself
also you need to realize
that your perception is subjective, right?
So it's your opinion due to
all the things that you have
in your head and the way you
were educated and raised,
that you a specific thing to
do is wrong or doesn't work,
but maybe another person
has a different
perspective on that, right?
And for this reason, it's
important to use I messages.
So to use things like, I
believe this is wrong, right?
Or in my perception, the
work that you delivered
is not meeting the standard.
Don't just say it as a
general rule of nature,
that the specific things
that another person does
are wrong or are not working
or whatever, but rather,
make it clear that this is
your specific perception.
And the one side of this is
that, this is humility, right?
You acknowledge that maybe other people
might have other perceptions.
And maybe also, in some instances,
you believe this is rather likely,
I mean, it's possible, right?
But the other side of that is that,
your perception is never wrong, right?
In the sense that another
person cannot tell you that,
no, you didn't have the perception, right?
So if you bring a point of
feedback to the other person,
if you phrase it as an I
message, and the person says,
I don't believe that,
I don't agree with you.
You can always say, well, you know,
I'm talking about my
perceptions, believe it or not,
but this is the perception
that I have, right?
And it's pretty much
impossible for the other person
to say that you cannot
have the processional,
you are not allowed to
have the perception,
this is not actually your perception,
because well, it is the perception, right?
And now we can argue whether
it's justified or not,
but this is the perception that I have
when looking at your work, right?
So you may be I have another opinion,
but still my perception is that
this piece of work is subpar, right?
So this is of course, an
important way how to phrase it.
So now to framework that you
can use to give your feedback.
This framework has four
steps, and from my experience
if you use this framework
to deliver your feedback,
very rarely somebody leaves
the conversation deeply hurt,
and almost always, there
some constructive point
that the other person can take
out of your feedback, right?
So what are the first steps?
The first step is, clearly
state your perception
in an I message just in the way
that we talked about it, right?
So say, I perceived
that you did this work,
and from my perspective,
this is just not the way
it's supposed to be, right?
So start with an I message,
with the perception
that you share to make a
specific point of feedback.
The second point is, give examples.
So names specific instances
where you observed
the things that you
would like to talk about
to make a tangible and to
not make a just an assertion,
but rather something based on facts.
So say, for instance,
you know, when I looked
at the document that
you handed over to me,
I saw that you wrote this
thing in this specific way,
which in my perception isn't
good for these reasons, right?
And now this is the third
point, tell the person
why you believe that a certain
action or a certain behavior,
or piece of work that the person
competed is maybe not good,
and tell them why this
is actually relevant,
why is it important
that the person does it
in a specific thing, explain
to him so that it's intuitive
and insightful for the person
why he actually needs to change.
And then the fourth thing
important, give an advice,
give a recommendation, how the
person actually can improve
and change the way, maybe
from your experience
what you learned when you
were younger, whatever,
try to help the person how
to actually improve the work.
Don't just tell them that
what is doing is wrong,
it doesn't work, et cetera,
but try to give him something
that he can work with in order to improve.
So now let's make an example
of how that could work out, right?
Let's pretend that we are
having a feedback conversation.
And you are junior colleague of mine.
And actually, I'm noticing
that in many of your pieces
of work, you make lots of
orthographical and grammar errors,
and I'd like to give you
that feedback, right?
So we could sit together
and I could open something
like, hey, I'd like to give
you just a point of feedback
if that's okay for you.
I was reviewing your work
recently and on several instances
in my perspective, I'm
noticing that you are doing
quite a lot of orthographical
and grammar errors,
and actually much more
from what I would expect
is appropriate and would
be expected in your role.
Let me give you a few examples
so that you know what I'm talking about.
So the board document
that we created yesterday,
I was reading it, and
before we were actually able
to send it out, I fixed over
10 orthographical errors.
In another instance last week,
you wrote the press release,
if you may remember it, and in there,
there were these four errors that I fixed.
So these are now, these two
instances where you made
quite a couple of lots of
orthographical and grammar errors
in your piece of work, and
this isn't great, right?
And also for you to help you understand,
just doesn't work because
we work in consulting
with clients, our clients
pay, of course, a lot of money
as we all know for services,
and they expect highest levels of quality
in the work that we deliver.
And if they see a piece of paper from us,
which contains this amount of errors,
actually any error at all,
it might cast the shadow on our work,
that we're actually not
giving attention to details,
that we don't really care,
that we are not really giving
our best to make that piece of
work the best that we can do,
and this is just not meeting
the professional standards
that we have here in our organization.
And just a few advice, a few
tips that may have helped me
in the past in order to improve,
so usually if I correct
an important document,
I like to print out and
then have it in front of me,
and then read it, because this way,
it takes me to spot all the errors.
And the second thing
that also always do is,
I use the the standard
orthographical error checking,
that programs like Microsoft Word have.
So also advise you that
whenever you send out
such a document, always load
it a text editor like that,
and make sure that all the errors
that are popping up in there,
that you fix them before
you actually send it out.
So cut here, I hope you
understood where I'm heading.
I hope you also see and
understand that, usually,
if you deliver the feedback in this way,
very rarely the other person
has any grounds of saying,
you know, this is unfair,
or this is not right,
or this is just not the way it is, right?
Because I mean, you gave specific examples
where you base your feedback on you,
you phrase it as an I message,
you talk about your perceptions,
and its effect that you're
having these perceptions, right?
So the other person cannot
say you're not having them
because that is just how
it is, you have them.
And you also try to
help the person, right?
So usually these leaves
everybody on a constructive note.
And I believe that if you
deliver this feedback this way,
you would much more professionally
than many other people
do, and all your people
you work with, we just
appreciate this a lot.
So let me know what you think.
Do you have any
experiences on the feedback
that you received or maybe that you gave?
What are your learnings?
Leave a comment down below,
I'd love for you to hear about it.
And if you got some
value out of this video,
please press the like button.
And of course, subscribe
below to this channel
in order to learn more about
things that might help you
in the first years of your career.
Thank you.
This is Heinrich, from Firm Learning.